support for big thing comes from
Microsoft delivering people ready
enterprise solutions designed to help
companies do more with less details at
microsoft com / people ready
I'm Thomas Cooley I'm the Dean of the
stern school of business at New York
University I'm also a professor of
economics
well I think they're going to be a lot
of a lot of new opportunities and other
sectors where we see people being
interested is in entrepreneurship so
there's a greater emphasis on wanting to
create new businesses new business
models there is a lot of interests among
our students in social entrepreneurship
is really an interesting generational
shift that's occurred and we see more
people who want to do well and do good
at the same time there are going to be
jobs on Wall Street there'll be
different jobs they won't be as highly
compensated but there's always going to
be a demand for people to manage assets
to restructure businesses to negotiate
mergers and acquisitions so our students
if they have a passion for it are still
going to seek jobs in finance and
they're there they're well aware of the
effect that this crisis is going to have
on their their economic prospects but
they still see that as an interesting
industry to work in and you know i think
the number of jobs in the compensation
will shrink but they'll still be there
the other thing that's that interests a
lot of people in nowadays is median
technology I think it's very difficult
to tell how the media industry is going
to evolve it's clear that it's going
through a crisis of its own of it's very
own making in some sense and but a lot
of our students see real opportunities
on the other side of that so it's an
interesting and interesting evolutionary
time
it's a very different environment and
the you know the search for seed money
and seed financing and that sort of
thing are are more difficult and
environment like this people are more
sensitive to risk at the same time I
think it's a time of opportunity because
it's a time when emerging businesses the
firms that have a good business model I
can't acquire talent can find more
people willing to take on some career
risk in order to to pursue an idea and
really put in the sweat equity that's
required to succeed in an
entrepreneurial venture so I think and
you know that's the upside of it that
that there there's more talent available
who are willing to willing to take those
kinds of those kinds of risks and they
see the the risk-reward trade off as
being a good one at this point in time
better than it would be when the
alternative is some enormously paying
job that at an investment bank
well I I think the most the most
exciting opportunities are that I mean
the most exciting business plans that
I've seen are people who are really
looking at at taking advantage of the
opportunities and alternative energy and
green technologies also in the
healthcare field I think there's an
enormous amount of entrepreneurial
enthusiasm about improving the health
care system in the health care delivery
system and finding new technologies for
for managing and delivering healthcare
the interesting thing is that these are
all that these are all things that
reflect priorities that we have set out
as a nation and and they are in some
sense very underdeveloped sectors that
are that that haven't been invested in
to the extent that other sectors had
probably far too much creative energy
went into the world of financial
innovation not enough into you know
healthcare innovation and and and the
alternative energy innovation so I think
we're going to see some some very
exciting developments in those in those
areas
discount the possibilities of extreme
events and and so just as a few years
ago people were probably a way too
short-sighted and how they thought about
developments and finance and real estate
you know now there's probably a tendency
to be a bit too short-sighted about the
problems that are created by the current
downturn right now I think that people
have to understand that as bad as this
recession is and and will be for a
little while it will end and will come
out of it and that that that represents
an opportunity I'll give you an example
of this there's a phenomenon act in
economics that that people talked about
called the Great Moderation Ben Bernanke
the chairman of the Fed wrote about the
Great Moderation and the phenomenon is
this that beginning in in the early
1980s the volatility of the economy and
economies throughout the developed world
decreased so they didn't fluctuate as
much and after 20 years we began to sort
of study this as a phenomenon is it due
to innovation that's one theory was it
due to better central banking that was
another but a third possibility is that
rude just had 20 years of pretty good
luck at but once people built into the
their expectations that lack of
volatility you know even the recession's
we had in that period we're relatively
mild and short-lived so I think that
people began to discount risk way too
much they did not understand or did not
want to face the reality of what the
risks are what is the risk of giving
somebody a mortgage that they can't
afford on the hope that the house is
going to appreciate in value but it's a
mistake that that's been made over and
over
and people tend to forget about it
and it's certainly true that if business
leaders conveyed truthfully all the
things that they were worried about it
might have the effect of a
self-fulfilling prophecy but what is
true what's striking to me about the
current situation the current business
environment is how few business leaders
have stood up and stood out as principal
articulate spokesman spokespeople for
for for what policy should do for what
businesses should do there are no
business leaders there in in the panic
of 1907 it was JP Morgan who rushed to
the rescue of the financial system in
the US economy and there is no one with
that kind of clout in the modern world
no one even willing to stand up and and
speak out very much it's been
astonishing how silent business leaders
our support for big thing comes from
Microsoft delivering people ready
enterprise solutions designed to help
companies do more with less details at
microsoft.com / people ready